hi Hannah hi Steve I know I co as I said
John Gina sale oh that hurts listen with
a Karmann Ghia core yattaman tightness
Oh God come gear call your soul and how
would you say put any how do you hate
too bad oh I'm thumbnail come now hey
what we're going to try to do in these
videos is because in every language
there are certain things that people
have to say for example too bad or the
way of saying too bad there's a way of
saying greetings for example right or
even things like why because way when
I'm young whatever and so I we were
talking about doing a series of videos
and euro and hung google and we will
compare how these basic ideas are
expressed in the two languages and I
know from personal experience that even
if you know how in Korean is a lion
because actually have to review it many
many times hey so and you need many
examples because it's different like
it's structured differently it's
different words and so maybe through
these discussions we can create a bunch
of examples for you know therefore or if
or different tenses and then people can
go and to a spot in English or in Korean
or eventually in other languages and
practice so we should try to say the
same thing in in Korean night hey Miss
Hannigan done Oh tongue tie a piece upon
Naomi [ __ ] [ __ ] on 0800 mahamaya day
manyak her
Hey Angulo row hmmm ha myung net is if
or money man yak your register hey Roger
Crockett M&L there for cruelty money
you're ready sir des neige mmm cheese
singer girl good yomo kumoi go in
unserem McGee surrounded a drag hey hun
yamaha virago sir Andre hang Go Go kumoi
goes even surround a big a hey how do
you say a common community evangelist
all groan is it hung go Goa wait pan pan
under TV shua take a sword katana and so
dannon Jackie today we all sang erotic
oh you got a YouTube video de tomaso
pantera naked on over to you saw Kevin
Hollander dog toy video Rococo hammer on
your walk with one and they told me to
similar to get that atom bomb at el tuyo
e puri separate a single man dick we
again good Tom Tom how do you say top
top bunk a no to punch a top birthday
schumi yo yo oh man cruelty today name
hey Yamato your Chi Chi su salud chi Chi
well Crona lu li vivo tenon salam be
know how do you say yummy yummy my
opinion jose zuniga and 1 John 1 John
jaaniya um boquete kitchen video I'm
look like a descriptive and ortho I'm
gay I need a name shizuka Jovi c 60 man
how does have am daddy yeah Timmy gay
you forget your hunger pursuant to kiss
and tell good okay man hmm oh cool man
cool we'll stop there come on okay
Yogi's Eureka zr1 Eureka's okay well I
good me so let's stop here and we'll get
some reactions from people and we will
in the meantime prepare and some
examples I mean we already have a list
of some mighty your soul a column
concepts call them structures patterns
that exist in English that exist in
Korean and also we will try to put these
as lessons put it into link so people
because the first time you hear it it's
always that interesting but of course
you can't remember and I find that I
have to review these over and over and
then I read and listen and then I have
to go back again and review these the
sort of what I call the bits and pieces
as opposed to the bigger picture of
listening and reading too interesting
content so it'll be an experiment ok ok
I hope this works right home so I'm
young a gazelle yes
okay bye for now bye